[Musica]
Il mio compito quotidiano è quello di
guidare alla salute al benessere e alla
felicità le persone quindi tutti noi e i
nostri animali
iniziando da ciò che mangiamo
vi chiederete il perché perché penso che
possiamo davvero avere cura della nostra
salute
iniziando da ciò che mangiamo e ciò che
portiamo in tavola una tavola che quindi
sarà idealmente apparecchiata con piatti
e ciotole e quindi adatta anche ai
nostri animali perché un cibo sano può
essere condiviso e questo avrà dei
vantaggi Non solo per la salute delle
persone degli animali ma anche per
l'ambiente
vi chiederete anche come deve essere
questo cibo
secondo secondo me deve essere semplice
per prima cosa
locale
prevalentemente vegetale e sano e in
questo modo Sarà adatto anche alla
salute dell'ambiente più sostenibile di
quella che è stata la tendenza dei
nostri ultimi anni
in questi ultimi anni abbiamo in qualche
modo scoperto o riscoperto che esiste
una sola salute che per gli addetti ai
lavori si chiama è nota come One Health
e che ha a che fare con la salute delle
persone della Terra e degli animali che
la abitano
ha a che fare con l'agricoltura con il
modo in cui coltiviamo le colture con i
farmaci e le sostanze chimiche che
utilizziamo per impedire che le piante
si ammalino con l'acqua che utilizziamo
ha che fare tantissimo con le condizioni
di lavoro di coloro che lavorano la
terra ha a che fare con gli allevamenti
intensivi
con il modo in cui alleviamo i nostri
animali con gli antibiotici le sostanze
farmacologiche che utilizziamo per non
farli ammalare con l'acqua che
sprechiamo negli allevamenti intensivi
con il cibo che utilizziamo per far
crescere gli animali
niente di tutto ciò è separato da noi e
ha a che fare con la nostra salute
e allora io ho un sogno
io sono un medico veterinario e molte
cose Ovviamente le ho imparate
all'università ma tantissime le ho
imparate da quelli che io chiamo i miei
maestri che sono tante persone per
fortuna e anche molti animali e quella
che io vi racconto stasera me l'ha
insegnata pepita il mio primo cane
pepita era un cane dolcissimo
delicatissimo sia nel corpo che
nell'animo e aveva la cute quasi Rosa
come quella dei maialini e delle sue
problematiche cutanee io i miei colleghi
non ci capivamo più nulla provavamo
prodotti provavamo terapie senza capirci
niente devo essere sincera e non
risolvevamo mai niente finché un giorno
io ero già diplomata in terapia
alimentare umana che possiamo dire il
mio secondo grandissimo amore ero in
cucina quindi non avevo il camice ma
avevo il grembiule e Avete presente quei
momenti in cui vi vengono delle idee
meravigliose
all'improvviso e a me spesso arrivano in
cucina
pepita era ai miei piedi come sempre
sperando che cadesse qualcosa dal tavolo
io stavo preparando il pranzo per le mie
figlie Angelica e Margherita che sono
due gemelle che all'epoca avevano due o
tre anni Erano molto piccole oggi invece
hanno quasi 14 anni e
io guardavo pepita Lei mi guardava con
degli occhi intelligenti grandi
spalancati io guardavo le crocchette di
ceci che stavo preparando al forno
perché io sono vegetariana da molti anni
e forse alla fine di questo discorso
capirete anche il perché
a un certo punto d'istinto ho preso una
crocchetta era appena intiepidita per
era appena uscita dal forno
lo spezzata e ho detto a pepita Dai
vieni
lei si mise a correre in cerchio come
faceva quando era strafelice ed è una
scena che io non posso dimenticare
faceva le capriole inciampava a un certo
punto si mise a camminare su due zampe
andò alla ciotola e mangiò tutto di un
fiato
da quel momento
io ho davvero pensato che
la nostra salute passa da quello che noi
portiamo sulla nostra tavola ed è nato
in me il desiderio di condividere con la
mia famiglia le ricette le stesse
ricette per tutti noi tutti erano molto
felici di dividere questi pasti
e Pipita non ebbe mai nessun problema
anzi delle sue problematiche cutanee non
ci fu più traccia problematiche su cui
noi ci eravamo scervellati veramente
così a vuoto
da quel momento si è fatto strada in me
il desiderio
di condividere questi pasti e ho
compreso quello che tutti noi conosciamo
a parole cioè che la salute passa per
quello che noi portiamo sulla tavola ma
in quel momento io ho portato quello che
noi tutti conosciamo il siamo quello che
mangiamo no lo diciamo spesso
quello è stato un momento in cui io ho
portato questa frase dentro di me Io
l'ho portata dentro al mio cuore e lì
rimarrà sempre
il nostro piatto e le loro ciotole
dovrebbero essere costituite
prevalentemente da cibo fresco in modo
tale da ridurre al massimo le sostanze
chimiche che noi introduciamo nel nostro
organismo e questo avrà un risvolto
positivo non solo sulla nostra salute ma
anche su quella dei nostri animali e su
quella del nostro ambiente
e possiamo rispolverare la nostra
vecchia abitudine di andare al mercato
di soffermarci Per prima cosa Sulle
bancarelle di frutta e verdura di
pensare che i vegetali hanno ancora una
loro stagione e che mangiare pomodori e
melanzane a gennaio come Tra l'altro io
ho fatto per molti anni ha un impatto
sulla nostra salute a un impatto sul
nostro ambiente soprattutto
mangeremo dei piatti cucinati con amore
e cura e dedizione E quell'amore che noi
metteremo quando andremo al mercato a
fare la spesa e porteremo poi in cucina
quando prepareremo i nostri piatti per
la nostra famiglia non solo ci renderà
più sereni più rilassati ma anche più
coerenti con il sentimento che proviamo
per le persone e gli animali che
dividono con noi questo viaggio
Scusate possiamo cercare di
tenere a mente una cosa molto importante
che quando mangiamo un cibo cucinato con
amore e cura non solo saremo più sani ma
saremo più felici e questo è addirittura
scritto su studi scientifici di
alimentazione e medicina sia umana Che
animale che ci dicono esattamente che le
emozioni positive ci curano ci salvano E
questa scienza si chiama pnei
la psico neuroendocrino immunologia che
non è nata oggi è stata
codificata per la prima volta nel 1930
però è opportuno che noi la ricordiamo
la Play ci dice che davvero essere
felici salva la nostra salute e ci
protegge dalle malattie
la Play ci dice anche di fare estrema
attenzione alle emozioni negative e a
tutte le delusioni la rabbia e la
tristezza che ogni giorno ingoiamo
perché le emozioni negative hanno come
organo bersaglio il nostro sistema
immunitario e avere un sistema
immunitario debole vuol dire spalancare
la porta a ogni tipo di malessere di
disturbo di malattie anche molto grave
non tanto perché il sistema immunitario
sia uno scudo difensivo che è sempre
quell'immagine di guerra di noi contro
loro contro virus contro batteri quanto
ci impedisce di armonizzarci con
l'ambiente in cui viviamo e quindi di
considerare nemici i peli dei nostri
animali polline dei meravigliosi fiori
della Primavera
cellule stesse del nostro organismo
contro cui noi spariamo le cartucce
delle nostre armi
con un estremo danno per il nostro
organismo quindi dobbiamo fare estrema
attenzione alle emozioni negative
ma non evitarle e imparare a vivere
insieme a loro
E allora cosa possiamo fare da domani
mattina e ogni giorno della nostra vita
diventiamo consapevoli e connettiamoci
con la nostra terra
Iniziamo a fare una spesa sana dai
nostri produttori locali
Vi mostro alcuni dati
dell'organizzazione Mondiale della
sanità aggiornati al 2020
Ogni anno una persona consumano 90 kg di
carne 70 kg di latte e derivati 50 kg di
zucchero soltanto Negli anni cinquanta i
chili di zucchero erano solo 5 con
questi dati la nostra alimentazione
moderna si è totalmente allontanata da
quella che è la dieta mediterranea che
non è più quella autentica
che era a base di cereali verdure legumi
frutta semi e frutta secca e condimenti
di buona qualità
quelle che io chiamo le sette magiche
categorie che sono Se ci pensate come le
sette note della musica con cui noi
possiamo suonare la nostra musica a
tavola ogni giorno diversa a cui Voi
potrete aggiungere il pesce i formaggi
le uova e la carne
a seconda del vostro sentimento verso il
regno animale Io ho scelto di non
mangiare animali e derivati da molti
anni e Vegan si chiama chi fa questa
scelta io preferisco non parlare di una
scelta etica perché è una cosa
impegnativa ma preferisco parlare di una
scelta di amore verso il regno animale
che non si può imporre a nessuno ma che
io sono sicura sia la strada verso una
salute diversa verso quella One Health
che io ho studiato sui libri che per me
inizia il mercato quando faccio la spesa
scelgo gli ingredienti
dei miei acquisti continua in cucina
mentre preparo i pranzi e le cene per la
mia famiglia e tutti i miei altri
animali
perché siamo una cosa sola con tutto il
creato
vi lascio un ricordo di questo evento
auguro a tutti voi un momento da portare
per sempre nel vostro cuore
per me è questa ricetta
La ricetta che ha cambiato la mia vita
Grazie a tutti
Grazie grazie mille
[Musica]